so what i tell my pms is always be
passionate about a problem not about a
solution same thing for entrepreneurs if
you're passionate about a problem and
you really focus on the problem and on
the audience you actually are more
likely to come up with a good solution
because you're not married to a solution
and you don't get stuck if that solution
fails you can easily
come up with another solution for the
same problem
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm joined today by a great
great friend of mine an amazing investor
entrepreneur
product expert amir schwart head of
product for the developer platform
twitter amir is the head of product for
the developer platform at twitter and a
venture partner at innovation endeavors
previously he held executive roles at
amazon slack google and microsoft he is
the author of two books on designing
bots and building apis the developers
love
amir welcome to 20 minute leaders
how you doing great great to be here
again you were the first episode of the
series i remember that it was a lot of
fun it was a lot of fun it took a big
risk from the middle of corona no risk
it was just like crazy just to see
people to have a good conversation with
someone that was delightful amazing so
in the next 20 minutes i want to dive
deep into creating products that are not
only good but they suck less yes
definitely and you know i'm here your
your history with microsoft google
twitch amazon slack
twitter having acquired reshuffle now
head of platform for the apis and
developers
i can't think of anybody better in the
world
to dig into this topic than you and so
i'm really excited to to pick your
branding in these next 20 minutes or so
what does it mean for you to create
products that suck less
i think it's um if i had to distill it
into one word it would be empathy
empathy is super strong you need to
develop empathy to the person that
you're building the product to so if you
if i had to distill it to something is
to develop the feeling of empathy with
your audience uh and and build a product
that they really need and they really
love that's that's how i look at it so
what does that actually tangibly mean
you know to build empathy with your
audience so i'll give you a few examples
where i failed and then how i
corrected my failure to build products
that suck less
so my first experience was at google i
was responsible for the startup program
at the time
and
we built a portal for
entrepreneurs so the idea was
entrepreneur would want to know how to
work with google and they would come
into this portal and learn about all the
resources that we have and we did a
design sprint and we brought and i
designed the first uh page of course um
and then we brought entrepreneurs to
actually do some user testing and the
most common word that they
said to describe the site was confused
wow they were super confused about the
site about the value didn't understand
anything
and that was a big like oh moment
for me like so can i say is that
okay anything you want
so that was like oh i didn't do my job
right and i learned that it was my my
early days in product i learned that
that happens a lot um so we did the
design sprint and we did we experimented
with few uh with a few designs and we
did a new data architecture and at the
end we brought um different
entrepreneurs back and the most common
word to this describe is i get it i
understand why google is good for me so
that's one example
i we developed a lot of empathy we
understood during that design sprint
what developers are what entrepreneurs
are looking for what are they what are
their motivations the fact that they
have maybe five minutes to understand
what is the value they can't dive deep
into they don't need a lot of word they
just like give them the value front and
center so that was a very interesting
learning experience but what happens to
you as you leave the room with the
initial entrepreneurs that are saying
confused and now you're sitting back and
you're reflecting and you have to decide
on some action steps to to change things
what does that strategy look like for
you so we did a process that was
developed in stanford called design
sprints and the key here is to re
release yourself from a solution and
really immerse yourself in a problem the
problem is entrepreneurs landing on a
dev site and they need to unders the
need is to understand how google could
help them
so instead of focusing on what is good
for google and what are like the
programs that we offer like you need to
start thinking about what is the value
that you're delivering and
as a as an entrepreneur i landed what
what's in it for me
right so you switch your point of view
to the customer's point of view and you
start playing with different designs so
now you go into ideation stage and you
look at different design and now with
the new lens you look at all these
designs and you say okay this actually
resonates and you bring other people and
they share their experience and you get
a lot of signals and then you actually
uh verify those designs with new
entrepreneurs right and you might get it
wrong again and then you try it again
but usually you get it more right
because once you change once you develop
this empathy once you change this slide
from what is what is good for google to
what is good for entrepreneurs you will
create a much better product
i can talk about another experience that
was pretty interesting if you're
still
interesting for you um when i joined
twitch
we already spent a lot of time and money
building a marketplace
for integrations between twitch and
other games
um i think the amount of time that we
spent before i joined was about five
years of person time to develop that's
enough so we were really bought into
that marketplace but that marketplace
performed really really poorly
nobody went into that marketplace and
even if they went into that marketplace
they people didn't know what to do there
and didn't find value
and i was tasked with fixing that uh
that problem
um and the way i did it is again this
the only way i know how to build good
products is to immerse myself with the
audience so i started interviewing um
users and i asked them why don't you
like the basic need was vetted they
wanted to integrate their games with the
experience of twitch but they didn't
understand why they need the marketplace
and they didn't care about going and
sifting through different they wanted us
to tell them
what's the right integration so instead
of building this
big ass marketplace with search and
recommendation and ai and all of that we
created an experience that says the
minute you edit your page will recommend
three integrations that fits your needs
and that moved from conversion of 1.6
to 75
conversion
and our users were happier and they were
more inclined to actually recommend
these integrations to other users so
and that cost us that experiment cost us
two weeks to develop wow so we moved
from like multi-year projects to a few
experiments
basically we moved from
a project that took us multi-years
to a project that took us two months but
actually delivered the entire value that
our customers were looking for and it
sounds to me that a common pattern that
we can start seeing in terms of these
things is that sometimes these week or
two experiments take taking a look back
rethinking the strategy that you've been
playing out for months can actually be
pivotal to your success right 100 and
it's usually you suffer from you know
sunk loss fallacy is you have invested
so much in this project and people are
dependent they spend their time and
blood and tears on this project wow so
what i tell my pms is always be
passionate about a problem not about a
solution same thing for entrepreneurs if
you're passionate about a problem and
you really focus on the problem and on
the audience you actually are more
likely to come up with a good solution
because you're not married to a solution
and you don't get stuck if that solution
fails you can easily
come up with another solution for the
same problem so as you're approaching
now you know as head of platform within
twitter previously co-founder and chief
product officer of reshuffle
you know beyond the the tangible
actionable steps how has your thinking
evolved when you're thinking through
these strategic scenarios as a leader
you know as a product leader so first of
all the thing that you need to develop
is uh being humble
you need to understand through a lot of
experimentation that you're mostly wrong
in many cases
and that you need to um
experiment in order to decide you need
to have a thesis you need to have a core
thesis that you're really passionate
about you need to focus on the impact
that you want to deliver but that impact
could be delivered in multiple ways and
it's your job as a leader to show people
where they need to be and to empower
them to find their path because if you
don't if you are very prescriptive
you are going to lose you need to hire
people that are smarter than you i
really like to work with people that we
talked about it last time i really like
to work with people who are much smarter
than me to give them a mission that is
hard and to empower them to actually
reach that mission and if you do that
and you get enough luck on your side
you'll be successful and so you you've
seen both you know big corporates
medium-sized corporates but also the
starters yep i'm guessing that it's
harder to do a lot of these steps as
you're growing the company because you
just have many more people with many
more opinions
but from from what you're seeing
what are some interesting steps that an
entrepreneur can do to
to raise a culture that that is that is
humble that is asking those critical
questions so the first thing you need to
do is hire the right people and empower
them basically fire yourself from the
role so if you're let's say you're an
entrepreneur that's really passionate
about product and you hire a vp of
product you need to actually give them
the power to make impactful choices
places where i see this fail is
entrepreneurs that hire people to
execute on their plan instead of giving
them the power to actually uh to be
empowered to do this
an example i do this in uh in big
corporates is i let the people who are
least senior talk first
because they're closest to the problem
and if the most senior person talks in
the room then everybody aligns to that
person but if you start from the least
senior you usually hear the most the
smartest thing that actually makes sense
was people who have actually immersed
themselves with the problem so you can
build mechanisms even if you're a
startup you can build mechanisms like
that to make sure that everybody's heard
that everybody's included and that you
haven't spent too much money on people
that just execute your job because if
they if you're hiring people that just
execute on a vision that you create you
you probably need to pay much less now
amir you know you're for the past so
many years you've been dealing with
product and you've seen product
growing in different organizations why
are you so passionate about product what
is it about this world that just
fascinates you i'm really if i'm sitting
with you for coffee and i'm energized by
how you talk about products uh i think
it's because i come from a family of
farmers and you need to grow something
and i'm not really good i i guess i'm
not good at farming i haven't really
earnestly tried it but like for me
product is uh is creation and when you
create something from zero there wasn't
something and now you did some work and
now there's a thing that actually
impacts and it doesn't matter when
you're creating a physical product or a
program
i managed a google start i we talked
about it i managed a google startup
program and every time i walk in san
francisco and i see someone with the
t-shirts of the google startup program i
get like wow and that's passionate for
me like i i think that impacting people
and giving them the platform to innovate
is is something that is a core theme for
in my life like letting people unleash
their creativity so you you really are
an expert now in this world of of
developers and wow experience i don't
know if i'm an expert i'll i'll use that
title okay thank you but
you've seen developers work with
with the greatest companies and you're
you're really immersed yourself in
developer platforms where are we at with
the world
that you've had such a strong conviction
that this that this is the thing you
want to be working on so i think that
developers
are
amazing they their creativity powers so
many things if you think about
our phone it's a new thing right it's
been here for maybe 20 years and now
everything we do is through that phone
we pay our bills through that phone we
do our banking through that phone we we
take a ride through that phone we order
our food through that phone all of this
are things that developers uh built on
top of a platform so i'm really
passionate about developer platforms
because it gives developers the ability
to create things that i would never have
thought of um eric schmidt has a like a
very um good term he said like they
built android without knowing that
there's going to be spotify and uber and
lyft and all these amazing companies but
they knew that they're building a
platform that will enable that
innovation to happen and for me that's
really revolutionary if you
there's
few times in your career where you can
make an impact that actually enables all
the people to make an impact and
that's where i that's also my investment
thesis i love developer tools i love
developer platforms i love places where
we enable these creative and productive
people to do more amazing and so what
are some things about developers that
you've learned over the last few years
that you know as a developer may not
even be trivial for me when we're
looking at the grand scheme of things
when you're looking at a massive
population of developers around the
world so i think there's a few things um
the developers are opinionated and they
will tell you what's broken which is
amazing because users usually don't
right
users usually say yeah i don't like it
or i don't feel like using it developers
will tell you hey this is broken and
here are the three things that you
really need to fix they might not be
right but they're very opinionated and
they're usually rights so listening to
your developers is super useful if
you're building a tool i ask a tool or
service or a platform for developers i
ask my pms to meet developers at least
on a weekly basis really and they
develop a lot of value from just
listening to that audience the second
thing is that we're just at the tip of
the iceberg of what developers could do
i think that the world is going to
change to everything we do is going to
be touched by software i think we're
going to have software
invisible in everywhere that we do we're
going to talk to software we're going to
interact with software in ways that we
do not imagine um i've seen a startup
that can actually uh they claim that
they can actually
listen to your
thoughts if you if you vocalize them and
not say them so if i'm telling you
they can actually know what i'm thinking
about if i'm vocalized because you're
actually running the your words through
the through some sort of system that's
amazing and that's a that could be a
platform for so many interesting
innovations so i think developers are
the future and i think
that audience is underserved i think the
tools that we're using still suck
i think build still takes too long i
think that our developer tools could be
much much better i think we could spend
a lot less time on testing and doing a
lot of boring stuff and focus on
creativity and that's what i want to do
amazing now i want to close the loop
from from the beginning of our
discussion when we talked about making
products that suck less and you get a
few examples of transitions that you've
done within both google and twitch tell
me about an experience you've had
where you came you came into the
experience with the understanding that
that you need to and
immerse yourself with empathy and really
understanding your users and immersing
with the problem and it worked and it
works
yes um
one thing that i did that was kind of
successful was to bring developers
into a product in the data stage
and that worked really well because that
brings the validation early on before
you launch
many times when you release a product
you release it and it either is awesome
or it's not awesome and you only know at
the day of the launch
but something that we did at slack that
was pretty successful was to bring
developers into the design stage of the
product and then they gave us feedback
before we launched and then they built
the products that integrated with slack
before we launched we did that with
threads pretty successfully so when uh
when we launched threads
we actually had three partners that that
showed what's the power of threads
through an integration with slack
and that was
we got the validation very early on and
we brought our partners and developers
into the ideation and design and
building the product and we built it
together and now we had high conviction
that that will be successful and we were
right at that time i love it amir thank
you so much for coming here enjoying
having me i have three more questions
okay and i want to take you back to your
childhood okay
what fascinates you in your day-to-day
it's before there were developer
relations and dev tools what i wanted to
be an astronaut uh that really
fascinated me the core experience that i
had as a kid was either being extremely
bored
or extremely fascinated about about a
topic
so when i was bored i was depressed i
didn't i did i i was super sad like the
first few days of every vacation uh like
school vacation i was super like what am
i gonna do i'm gonna be super bored and
then i fell in love with something and i
just focused on it crazily so that was
my experience as a kid now when you're
saying focus on it crazily what does it
actually mean back then for you does it
mean just immersing yourself many many
hours
reading about being an astronaut and
taking pictures of and thinking about an
astronaut and writing a story about
being an astronaut and like and and the
second is like being a superhero what
does it mean what are the types of
superhero how can this superhero beat
this superhero so like either being
bored or super fascinated about usually
useless topic uh that really delighted
me but do you see that that same
behavior of course i'm the same per i
i'm probably not the same person but i i
feel like i'm either
super bored and i can't do boring stuff
and that's my i just can't do them or
i'm super passionate about a topic and
then i look at it and i think about it
at night and i wake up in the middle of
the night and write some notes about it
so i'm either super passionate about
something or very bored with it i love
it and today in your day today you've
done so much already but what inspires
you to continue you know you can really
do anything you want in the world right
now why why do you do what you do what
really inspires you in your day-to-day
it took me a lot of time to figure that
out and i tried a lot of roles
and what i found is that i'm a domain
specific person there are people who are
passionate about product there are
people who are passionate about
engineering i was passionate about a
domain i might and my domain was
developer platform so i did
marketing and advocacy for platforms and
i did i engineered some platforms and i
did product for some platforms but i
found that i'm i need to be passionate
about a topic and the top and the topic
of my career was developer platforms
very very cool and what are three words
you used to describe yourself
yeah that's that's a good one um i i
like douglas adams so i would say do not
panic would be my uh three words
because i
i tend to think that most things should
not cause panic uh and you should be
chill and if you're chill about life
then life treats you pretty awesome even
if like there's hard hardship which you
all experience
this was amazing and thank you for all
the inspiration over the years and being
the first episode and and here and i'm
inviting you to another episode in
another few hundred episodes thank you
for having me a lot of fun thank you
have a good one